[Musique]
pour répondre à cette question je dirais
que dans certains cas on peut prévoir
seulement quelques jours à la vie dans
d'autres corps 4 ainsi jo dans les corps
ramassés 7 a dû hausser ce qu'on espère
deux jours c'est pas c'est pas staps
savary toujours sa départ des situations
météorologiques
[Musique]
il faut reculer petit peu dans le temps
puis intéresser une expérience qui a été
fait par lawrence qui tenait générant
métérologue qui travaillent om haïti à
l'époque donc fait une expérience dans
les années 60 où il s'est dissimulé avec
un petit modèle numérique à 6 à 6,5
certains paramètres comme par exemple la
température et le vent alors le rien dit
donc prêt par son programme informatique
programme ssa et utilise un ordinateur
évidemment à l'époque les ordinateurs
n'étaient pas très puissant alors
lawrence démarre son sa simulation et
laisse aller les choses pour voir
évoluer la température et le vin par
exemple dans son petit outil numérique
avec le temps il trouvait que ça prenait
beaucoup beaucoup top calcul c'est
normal l'ordinateur et poterie but sera
lorsque le resist de faire c'est de
recommencer son expérience avec les
mêmes données
mais en changeant la précision c'est à
dire aller en diminuant la précision des
données
alors il refait la même expérience les
laisse aller les choses
après avoir terminé sa sa prévision
assez longue
il décide pour s'amuser de regarder les
deux prévisions y comparait alors il
s'aperçoit hilton à main que il
s'attendait en fait à ce que les prisons
se suivent et graduellement commencent à
diverger et organiques avec la même
précision
on n'a pas la même précision avec les
données de base mais il s'aperçoit que
lui comparé après un certain temps les
prévisions se mêlent totalement dit
virginie ça se peut pas voyons comme
pour comme les prévisions se met
totalement diverger une prévision que
prévoit le contraire de l'autre alors il
décide de recommencer il pense que ces
trois paix dans ses calculs il
recommence et de recommencer s'aperçoit
qu'il ne sait pas absolument pas trompés
à faire ce qu'il venait de mettre en
évidence c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sensibilité aux conditions initiales
ça pourrait s'exprimer une autre manière
en dix ans une petite variation dans
l'état initial par exemple de systèmes
physiques comme un cas qui nous occupe
c'est l'atmosphère mais va avoir une
incidence très important après seulement
quelques jours de prison
sion et ça c'est vraiment fascinant
parce que ça met en lumière toutes les
interactions qui sont totalement non
linéaire donc céder ses actions sont
vraiment très très complexe ce soit
c'est inhérent à l'atmosphère alors lui
de le mettre en lumière et c'est à
partir de ce moment là qu'ils commencent
à s'intéresser aux biarrots bien
développer tout ce qui était la théorie
du chaos et il y avait utilisé une
petite phrase vraiment pour aix et
d'exprimer un peu ce principe là le
battement d'aile d'un papillon au brésil
pourrait provoquer après un certain
temps
une tornade aux etats-unis c'était un
peu une manière de dire la petite
fluctuation ou la petite variation quand
on me l'a donnée dans l'état de basse va
avoir une incidence très très important
après un certain temps on peut
aujourd'hui on peut reproduire un peu
l'expérience de lawrence pour voir quel
sera l'impact d'une petite fluctuation
de petites variations qu'au bar en bas
on va forcer dans l'état initial pouvoir
faire des prévisions y voir l'impact
savoir dans le temps à pour une
prévision à mattison de prestige aux
quinze jours à l'état de la manière dont
fait actuellement on fait des prévisions
jusqu'à 16 16 jours et on utilise des
modèles qui sont extrêmement
sophistiqués des modèles planétaire qui
s'est mis tout ce qui se passe partout
l'océan et compagnie trois dimensions et
on peut le faire par exemple comparer
avec certains points des points fixes
par exemple pu regarder ce qui va se
passer pour nous peu importe alors nous
on va le faire d'une façon donc
quotidienne parce qu'on a une puissance
informatique vraiment aujourd'hui
alors on l'a fait et c'est intéressant
parce que si vous regardez par exemple
voir faire tourner le modèle sûr
seize vingtaine de jours on va le faire
sur cinq jours par dont on va le faire
une vingtaine de fois en changeant
légèrement les données de base on va
comparer par la suite les prévisions ce
qui est le plus intéressant dans les
paramètres métrologie que regarder c'est
la température incertaine niveau et on
va regarder par la suite comment ça se
passe où sûr il serait intéressant de
voir qu'après un certain soin dans
certaines situations météorologiques les
prévisions se mettre totalement diverger
abrite des fois deux jours trois jours
par certains cautionnement après quatre
jours cinq jours six jours et dans
certains corps car toi quand tout va
très bien jusqu'à seulement dix jours
grâce à mon père ça va permettre
d'évaluer ce qu'on appelle les 2 grippes
confiance en la prévision alors si on
voit que les prévisions divergent les
prévisions se met à diverger après
seulement deux trois jours on se dit bon
degré de confiance en la prévision est à
peu près 2 à 3 jours 6 à 10 verges après
4s jos à peu près 4 essieux et ça se
voit très bien graphiquement à l'aide de
ce qu'on appelle des météos g et c'est
une famille météo g qui sont d'aider
donc des des diagrammes qui expriment
des variations de ces variables pour 10
points donnait donc ça peut être ignorée
au québec dont tous peu importe ce lieu
ailleurs ailleurs sur la planète mais on
le voit tout de suite on voit tous deux
souhaitent en regardant sort on essaie
de trouver l'endroit où les prévisions
se met à diverger et on s'aperçoit que
dans certaines situations ça peut
diverger très rapidement dans d'autres
être apprécié ça dure et ça c'est très
pratique parce que qu'allié quand les
modèles sont très performants ou le
degré de confiance est élevé sur du long
autant on peut voir arriver des écoutes
fois à l'air froid qui arrive hiver on
peut voir arriver cinq six jours d'avis
des vagues de chaleur l'été on va
pouvoir le voir arriver là c'est assez
rapidement c'est tout et tout ça gharsa
ou mettez au grain
[Musique]
mais ça partout sur un papa partout dans
certains sites sur internet par exemple
le site de météo centre c'est le site de
l'université du québec à montréal
alors j'ai trouvé ça assez facilement
dans mon papier que j'ai écrit l'article
vous avez tout lien et vous allez
pouvoir voir les outils que moi
j'utilise pour savoir si je vois arriver
coup fois il s'est bien défini que les
prévisions du modèle sont toujours les
mêmes
même si on a changé légèrement les
données des initiales on va le voir très
très très clairement donc je peux
pouvoir m'avancer en disant moi je crois
que dans 5 jours il va avoir une vague
de froid qui s'installe puis ça
fonctionne assez bien parce qu'on voit
grâce à ces fameux météo g n'a alors
c'est vraiment une manière intéressant
de le faire et c'est fait aujourd'hui
sur une base quotidienne
imaginez ce que lawrence layton
marquerait lorenza ils font sur une base
quotidienne planétaire alors lui qui
avait même modèle que tard quand même
assez rudimentaire